let's start off by looking at two
important data relationships when you do
modeling in data store they are ancestor
relationships and have say relationships
starting off with the ancestor
relationship in data store it is
possible to specify that an entity has
an ancestor entity there are two
important rules for ancestor
relationships first of all it needs to
be assigned when the entity is created
and secondly it can never be changed so
those are things to think about when you
model an ancestor relationship and given
those rules please note that the
ancestor relationship is not the same as
the eca relationship in object-oriented
modeling in conference central we will
use the ancestor relationship for the
conference kind that you will create
shortly where the ancestor will be the
user who created the conference
technically speaking though since the
users are identified through their
profile entities so in this case the
conference's will have the key or the
profile entity as their ancestor key the
other relationship we will be using is
the has a relationship we will be using
this relationship to model conferences
which users are attending to do this we
will add a property to the profile
entity which specifies the attended
conferences so each profile will have a
property that contains the conference's
that they are attending observe that
this relationship can easily change we
can deregister from conferences and
register two new ones so it is not
bounded by the strict rules of the
ancestor relationship so those are the
basics of these relationships and that's
also enough theory for now time to do
some coding